we're asked at how many points did the
graph of y equals sine of theta and y
equal cosine theta intersect for theta
between 0 and 2 pi and it's 0 is less
than or equal to theta which is less
than or equal to 2 pi so we're going to
include 0 and 2 pi you know the possible
values for theta so to do this i've set
up a little chart for theta cosine theta
and sine theta and we can use this to
end the unit circle to hopefully quickly
graph what the graphs of y equals sine
theta and y equals cosine theta are and
then we can think about
how many times they intersect and maybe
where they actually intersect so let's
get started so first of all just to be
clear this is a unit circle this is the
x-axis this is the y-axis over here
we're going to graph these two graphs so
this is going to be the y-axis and it's
going to be a function of theta not x on
the horizontal axis
so first let's think about what happens
when theta is equal to zero so when
theta is equal to zero you're at this
point right over here let me do a
different color you're at this point
right over here on the unit circle and
what coordinate is that
well that's the point
one comma
zero
and so based on that what is cosine of
theta when theta is equal to zero
well cosine of theta is one and sine of
theta is going to be zero this is the
x-axis at the point of intersection with
the unit circle this is this is sorry
this is the x-coordinate at the point of
intersection with the unit circle this
is the y-coordinate let's keep going
what about pi over 2. so pi over 2
we are right over here
what is that coordinate
well that's now x is zero y is one so
based on that cosine of theta is zero
and what is sine of theta
well that's going to be one it's the y
coordinate right over here now let's go
all the way to pi now let's go to all
the way to pi we're at this point in the
unit circle what is the coordinate
well this is negative 1 comma 0. so what
is cosine of theta what's the x
coordinate here which is negative 1 and
sine of theta is going to be the y
coordinate which is 0.
now let's keep going now we're down here
at 3 pi over 2 if we go all the way
around to 3 pi over 2
what is this coordinate
well this is 0 negative 1
cosine of theta is the x coordinate here
so cosine of theta is going to be 0 and
what is sine of theta going to be
well it's going to be negative
one
and then finally we go back to two pi
which is making a full revolution around
the circle we went all the way around
and we're back to this point right over
here so the coordinate is the exact same
thing as when the angle equaled radio
equals 0 radians and so what is cosine
of theta well that's 1 and sine of theta
is
0. and from this we can make a rough
sketch of the graph and think about
where they might intersect so first
let's do cosine of theta
when theta is zero and let me let me
draw let me mark this off so this is
going to be when y is equal to one and
this is when y is equal to
negative 1.
so
y equals cosine of theta i'm going to
graph let's see theta equals 0 cosine of
theta equals 1. so cosine of theta is
equal to 1.
when theta is equal to pi over 2 cosine
of theta is zero
when when theta is equal to pi cosine of
theta is negative one
when theta is equal to
three pi over two cosine of theta is
equal to zero that's this right over
here and then finally when theta is 2 pi
cosine of theta is 1 again
is
1 again and the curve will look
something
will look something like this my best
attempt to draw it
make it a nice
smooth curve so it's going to look
something
something
something like this the look of these
curves should look somewhat familiar at
this point so it should look something
like this so this is the graph of y
is equal to cosine of theta now let's do
the same thing for sine theta when theta
is equal to zero sine theta is
zero
when theta is pi over two sine of theta
is one
when theta is equal to pi sine of theta
is zero
when theta is equal to three pi over two
sine of theta is negative one it is
negative one
when theta is equal to two pi sine of
theta is equal to zero
and so the graph of sine of theta is
going to look something
something
like
something like this my best attempt at
drawing it is going to look something
like this
so just visually we can think about the
question
at how many points do the graphs of y
equal sine of theta and y equal cosine
of theta intersect for this range for
theta for theta being between
0 and 2 pi including those two points
well you just look at this graph you see
there's two points of intersection this
point right over here and this point
right over here just over the between
zero and two pi these are cyclical
graphs if we kept going they would keep
intersecting with each other but just
over this 2 pi just over this 2 pi
range for theta you get 2 points of
intersection now let's think about what
they are because they look they look to
be
pretty close between between right
between 0 and pi over 2 and right
between pi and 3 pi over 2. so let's
look at our unit circle if we can figure
out what those values are let's it looks
like it looks like this is at pi over 4.
so let's verify that so let's think
about what these values are at pi over
4.
so pi over 4 is that angle or that's the
terminal side of it so this is pi over 4
pi over 4 is the exact same thing as a
45 degree angle
so let's do pi over 4 right over here so
we have to figure out what this point is
what that what the coordinates are so
let's make this
let's make this a right triangle
it's a right triangle and so what do we
know about this right triangle and i'm
going to draw it right over here to make
it a little clear this is a very top
typical type of right triangle so it's
good to get some familiar familiarity
with it so let me draw my best attempt
all right so we know it's a right
triangle we know that this is 45 degrees
what is the length of the hypotenuse
well this is a unit circle has radius
one so the length of the hypotenuse here
is one
and what do we know about this angle
right over here
well we know that it it too must be 45
degrees because all of these angles have
to add up to 180 and since these two
angles are the same we know that these
two sides are going to be the same and
then we could use the pythagorean
theorem to think about the length of
those sides so using the pythagorean
theorem knowing that these two sides are
equal what do we get for the length of
those sides
well let's call these this if this has
length a well then this also has length
a and we can use the pythagorean theorem
and we could say a squared plus a
squared is equal to the hypotenuse
squared is equal to one or two a squared
is equal to one
a squared is equal to one half take the
principal root of both sides a is equal
to the square root of one half which is
the square root of one which is one over
the square root of two
we can rationalize the denominator here
by multiplying by square root of two
over square root of two which gives us a
is equal to in the numerator square root
of 2 and in the denominator square root
of 2 times square root of 2 is 2.
so this length is square root of 2
and this length is the same thing so
this this length right over here is
square root of 2 over 2 and this height
right over here is also square root of 2
over 2. so based on that what what is
this coordinate point
well
it's square root of 2 over 2 to the
right in the positive direction so x is
equal to square root of 2 over 2
and y is where square root of 2 over 2
in the upwards direction in the vertical
direction the positive vertical
direction so it's also square root of 2
over 2. cosine of theta is just the it's
just the x coordinate so it's square
root of 2 over 2 sine of theta is just
the y coordinate
so you see immediately that they do and
they are indeed equal at that point so
at this point they're both equal to
square root of 2 they're both equal to
square root of two over two
now what about this point right over
here which looks right in between pi
and three pi over two so that's going to
be so this is pi this is three pi over
two it is right
it is right over here so it's another pi
over 4 plus pi so pi
plus pi over 4 is the same thing as 4 pi
over 4 plus pi over 4. so this is the
angle 5 pi over 4. so this is 5 pi over
4
so this is equal to 5 pi over 4 so
that's what we're trying to figure out
what is it what are the value of these
functions at theta equal 5 pi over 4.
well there's multiple ways to think
about you can even use a little bit of
geometry to say well if this is a 45
degree angle then this right over here
is also a 45 degree angle you could say
that the reference angle in terms of
degrees is 45 degrees and we can do a
very similar thing we can draw a right
triangle
we know the hypotenuse is 1.
we know that if this is a right angle
this is 45 degrees if that's 45 degrees
and this is also 45 degrees
and we have a we have a triangle that's
very similar it's actually they're
actually congruent triangles so
hypotenuse is 145 45 90 we then know
that the length of this side is square
root of 2 over 2 and the length of this
side is square root of 2 over 2 the
exact same logic we used over here
so based on that
based on that what is the coordinate of
that point
well let's think about the x value it's
squared of 2 over 2
in the negative direction we have to go
square to 2 over 2 to the left of the
origin so it's negative square root of 2
over 2. this point right over this time
this point on the x axis is negative
square root of 2 over 2.
what about the y value well we have to
go square root of 2 over 2 down in the
downward direction from the origin so
it's also negative square root of 2 over
2. so sine of this cosine of theta is
negative square root of 2 over 2 and
sine of theta is also negative square
root of 2 over 2. and so we see that we
do indeed have the same value for cosine
of theta and sine of theta right there
they're both equal to
are both at that point equal to the
negative the negative square root of two
over two